我行医到现在都快40年了
见过太多的人
他靠药物来把血糖血压
压得太低差点出事
有一位太太
她是我的糖尿病病人
她的先生每晚都睡不好
这我知道
家里的人他也会担心
说到血糖
又怕太高又怕太低
照顾的人晚上也睡不着
她先生怕他血糖
因为吃药打针降得太低了
所以呢他每天晚上紧张得要命
连带晚上都睡不好
他真的很辛苦耶
是喔这一集我要告诉
健康的人血糖高的人
怎么学会来稳定你的血糖
血糖高吃什么最好
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
来我跟你说
血糖不稳定
会对你有什么影响
血糖长期过高的人容易
口渴多尿疲倦
甚至于视力模糊
如果没有好好的控制
血糖就会慢慢的
伤害你的血管
将来心脏病中风还有肾脏病
等等的风险就跟着提高
血糖长期过低的人
就可能出现
头晕冒冷汗手抖
长期下来
也会刺激到心脏和血管
心律不整或心肌梗塞等等的风险
都跟着越来越多
而且免疫力
也会跟着越来越差
所以不是低血糖
就一定健康
血糖过高过低
都可能危害了你的心脏
严重还真的是会要命的耶
2习惯要戒掉
害血糖暴冲脂肪肝
想让血糖稳定
远离糖尿病并发症
这两个容易让
血糖飙高的习惯
一定要戒掉或者是减少
第一个习惯
喝蔬果汁吃水果大餐
你以为喝蔬果汁
吃很多水果就健康啦
错
曾经有一位80多岁的老阿公
他糖尿病40年
血糖控制得不错
有一天血糖突然飙到200 300
原来因为他每天早上
喝这么一大杯的蔬果汁
我知道
有人打一杯蔬果汁
使用的蔬菜水果
比一天吃的份量还多
对喔这样就会过量
而且吃下去的
果糖太多了
水果里面的果糖
要靠肝脏来代谢
你在短时间里面
吃太多的蔬果
肝脏反而负担过多
多余的果糖就会
转成为脂肪堆在肝脏里面
久而久之脂肪肝
可能就缠上你
糖尿病的人
吃什么水果
糖份才不会太高
你可以吃苹果蓝莓芭乐
这三种水果
甜度低而且安全
份量不要吃太多就是了
一天建议你吃
一颗苹果大小的份量就好了
饭后两小时再吃
血糖会稳定很多
第二个习惯太晚吃晚餐
你是不是常常
加班到很晚才吃晚餐
吃完后直接
躺在沙发上面滑手机
全身都不动
只有手指在那里动啊
问题是你吃进去的糖和热量
身体是没有时间去消耗它
睡觉的时候
胰岛素忙着降血糖
但追得不够快
清晨的时候
肝脏又会释放
一些糖份出来
早上起床血糖反而飙高
整天都很难稳定
怎么办
你尽量在晚上七点之前
就吃完晚餐
让身体有足够的消化时间
如果你加班到很晚才吃饭
吃完了以后
就起来走个十分钟
帮助血糖下降
避免你长出游泳圈来喔
血糖忽高忽低怎么办
2穴降糖解便秘
血糖高的人
问有什么方法
可以快速降血糖
按什么穴道可以降血糖
有这两个穴位超好用
控糖又顾脾胃
三阴交公孙
说到三阴交穴
它能帮你把血糖
还有所有的内分泌都调整好
一次还调理肝脾肾3个经络
你看是不是很厉害
真的耶
这两个穴位很好用耶
很好用耶
三阴交在内踝尖往上三寸
大概四个手指头的宽度
就是三寸的意思
你摸到有一个洞
它就叫做三阴交
我还记得你有说过
怀孕的人不能按三阴交耶
有可能
会有 可能会流产
妳真聪明耶很聪明喔
孕妇注意不要按喔
再来第二个控糖的就是
公孙穴
公孙穴它可以
调动脾的能量尤其是
容易便秘血糖不稳的人
通通都是特别赞的
很多糖友它脾比较弱
中医说脾主管消化和吸收的
如果脾不好
你吃进去的食物
就吸收不均匀
血糖容易忽高忽低
便秘也容易找上你
公孙穴在哪里呢
它的位置是在基骨
就是大趾的跖骨的基骨
在基骨往后
然后从后边这个地方
再往后头找一个拇指寸的大小
这个位置就叫做公孙穴
你常常按摩
三阴交和公孙这两个穴
使你的血糖更稳定
脾胃更健康
自然就能够改善便秘了
你按了这两个穴位
有什么感受呢
可以留言给我
无糖饮料竟让血糖飙
1茶降血糖
喝什么茶来降血糖
有一杯茶满不错的那就是
牛蒡茶
中医看牛蒡
有清热解毒利水通肠的功效
牛蒡会把身体里头
多余的糖和水份带走
让血管干干净净的
不容易堵塞
住进
而 起到降血糖降血压的作用
牛蒡茶怎么泡
市面上有卖这种
牛蒡的茶包
你拿一个马克杯
放牛蒡茶包进去
然后冲250cc的热开水
焖5分钟就可以喝了
很方便
很讚喔
这样糖友就来一杯
牛蒡茶还可以降血压血糖
闻起来也很香
喝起来也还口感不错
谁不能喝牛蒡茶
两种人要避免
第一怀孕的女性
当然是女性
第二风寒感冒
像是怕冷了
有点咳嗽这一类的感冒
不要
喝喝 了可能会不舒服
现在很多人
都很爱喝手摇饮
糖尿病的人适合
喝什么饮料
只要是无糖饮料就可以
红茶绿茶乌龙茶
无糖鲜奶茶牛奶都OK吧
但是这一种无糖饮料
健康的人糖尿病人都不要喝
就是有甜味剂的无糖饮料
根据研究
摄取大量人工甜味剂的人
罹患糖尿病的风险
是明显的提高
我们健康的人
最好不要吃甜味剂
是喔糖友真的要喝甜的话
建议你买
无糖饮料回家
自己加点蜂蜜
比外面加砂糖
或果糖的更好
饭后血糖不飙高
山药护血管降三高
饭后血糖降不下来的人
我最推荐你吃山药
有一次我朋友的朋友
说去做健康检查
发现血糖有点
高就 问我朋友
我血糖高
有没有什么办法
可以不吃降血糖药
但是却能够让我血糖降低
你有没有什么方法呀
我那朋友他是学医的
他就跟他说很简单啊
你把山药蒸一蒸来吃
每天吃一两二两
或三两的份量
结果几天后血糖就稳定下来了
再去检查血糖恢复到正常值
可见山药不只是
降血糖
真的能够帮助
血糖稳定喔
那山药不是淀粉吗
血糖高的人可以吃吗
好问题
重点就在山药那一点
黏黏滑滑的
黏液蛋白
它像一层天然的保护膜
能包住肠道里头的食物
让糖份慢慢的释放
避免饭后的血糖飙高上来
更棒的是
山药能够清理血管
防止脂肪的堆积
让心血管更健康
同时呢补肾又稳定血糖
是非常棒的降三高食物
美丽的太太
山药怎么吃最好啊
我知道
把山药拿来蒸或是拿来煮
都很好吃耶
你煮的山药小米瘦肉粥是不是
对啊山药小米瘦肉粥
还有山药排骨汤
都很好吃啊
这两道血糖血压都照顾到了
对吧
是啊
还有一个三高的人
吃也很好就是
煮成四神汤
你都喜欢怎样料理那个山药啊
留言给我们
名厨用1蔬菜煮汤
稳血糖近50
年高 血糖患者或者是糖友
炒菜别只靠盐和酱油
改用控血糖蔬菜
像是洋葱大蒜
不但香气十足
还能够降血糖
就算少盐它都很美味
洋葱可以降血糖吗
可以
洋葱的槲皮素
不只是延缓糖的吸收
还保护血管
日本天皇的御厨弟子
洼田好直
四十几岁的时候
罹患糖尿病
医生建议他打胰岛素
他希望能不依赖药物
每天就喝自己研发的洋葱汤
空腹血糖就从
两百降降降到一百三
而且完全没有吃一颗药
已经快五十年
你知道吗
这个洼田好直
现在已经90多岁了
还在餐厅里头当总料理长
活力满满的耶
哇好厉害喔
那洋葱汤要怎么做
我把份量和做法放在这里
你可以截图试做喔
洋葱1公斤大约4颗
昆布丝15g
大蒜1/2瓣
培根50g
白酱油1又2/3茶匙
酱油3/4大茶匙
醋2/3大茶匙
胡椒少许
水1200cc
那大蒜怎么吃
能控制血糖
临床证明
你可以每天吃
新鲜大蒜两公克
大约就是一瓣的份量
一颗大蒜的份量
连续几周就能稳血糖
这个大蒜的蒜素它可以
促进胰岛素的分泌
把血糖带进细胞
亲爱的粉丝们
我们已经开启会员频道了
如果你认同我推广中医
照顾自己健康的理念
欢迎每月小额支持
只要花两杯咖啡的钱喔
或成为VIP赞助者
有你同行
我们才能走得更远
真心感谢你哦